from Hollywood for September 14th 1981
you heard our theme song for the very
first time on show number one back then
our hosts were former Miss World
Marjorie Wallace and Young and the
Restless star Tom Halley's Burt Reynolds
Brooke Shields Elizabeth Taylor just a
few of the people you'll meet tonight
Mary Hart joined the show eight months
later I'm Mary Hart for Entertainment
Tonight as we were getting our start so
were most of today's biggest stars
seven-year-old drew Barrymore who
couldn't stop chewing gum through our
interview Rob Lowe with then-girlfriend
Melissa Gilbert even a 19 year old Tom
Cruise before he got braces and looked
like this I always kind of felt like an
outsider and somehow at this point I
just seemed to fit in and just what can
I say from legends like Lucy to newbies
like Heather Locklear 20 year old Robert
Downey jr. and Patrick Swayze they all
came to et to tell their stories I told
my mother I was living with the
stewardess because I was 16 years old
he's cruising so well right now that I
don't think I don't think even I could
screw it up and I've been told by people
in real life it hey you're a wimp on TV
you look huge okay my real name is Halle
Berry
the most iconic movies you bet et was
right there on the set
she's prostitute you know essentially
well mom at the movie bombs with people
like pointed me and say like it it's his
fault I'm not worried about that at all
I'm the center of all butts of jokes I
welcome them freely they're crazy
they're back they did some things in
this movie that have never been done and
I don't think anybody in their right
mind will ever try to do again in 1989
Paul McCartney invited us into his
Sussex England home where he did his own
take on our theme song
[Music]
yep no one else got this close to the
inner circle we spent a day in the light
with these two whitney getting makeup
ready before her first Grammys where she
was up for three awards any one of them
would make me happy and Michael Jackson
working on his moves behind the scenes
of beating people bring some type of joy
escapism magic to the world it's fun
looking back nearly 40 years but some of
our favorite moments were when the
biggest stars of today were just kids
are you nervous for your dad tonight I
really want to bite the road of ice but
I'm too young for that
[Music]